bonjour bruno ça a pris du temps à se
dessiner cet accord alors qu'on voit
redjep tayyip erdogan le président turc
qui arrive dans la salle
oui le président turc que l'on qui a été
le grand médiateur quand même entre les
russes et les ukrainiens sur cette
affaire des céréales tout simplement
parce qu'il faut le rappeler la turquie
et bien c'est elle qui contrôle en
quelque sorte les accès à la mer noire
puisque les détroits les deux des trois
bosses aurait et istanbul évidemment
permettre ou pas d'entrer dans la mer
nord donc dès le départ il a voulu jouer
un rôle actif et ses efforts sont
aujourd'hui
récompensés sous l'égide de l'onu on
voit là le secrétaire général antonio
goûter res qui s'assoit à côté du
dirigeant turc
voilà donc moments importants le monde
je vous le disais hé regardez ces 25
millions de tonnes de céréales
ukrainienne très attentivement depuis
des mois à une crise alimentaire global
couvre également c'est la perspective
pour les mois à venir cet accord doit
donc permettre de débloquer or il ya
deux volets dans cet accord on
l'expliquait tout à l'heure bruno les
céréales ukrainienne mais également les
grains et engrais russe qui servent à
beaucoup de pays notamment en afrique
oui mais alors à ce seul
nom comment sur le président de la
république monsieur le secrétaire
général sheikh ministre cheikh invité
la république de turquie l'accord
l'accord va être signée avec la présence
des nations unies de la république
d'ukraine de la république de turquie
bienvenue à cette cérémonie cher
invitait le secrétaire général monsieur
gunther s va d'abord prendre la parole
je le prie de bien vouloir s'exprimer
excellences mesdames et messieurs tout
est
aujourd'hui il ya une lueur sur la mer
noire une lueur d'espoir une lueur de
possibilités une lueur de soulagement
dans un monde qui en a besoin plus que
jamais je tiens à remercier et à
reconnaître toutes les parties prenantes
qui ont permis de rendre ce jour pro
possible toros tout d'abord le président
vous présente les douanes et le
gouvernement de la turquie
votre détermination votre persistance
ont été essentiels ont été instrumental
à chaque étape de ce processus
merci beaucoup
aux représentations de la fédération de
russie et de l'ukraine vous avez
réussi à paver la voie vers une
initiative qui sert l intérêt de tous et
ce en surmontant les obstacles vous
permettait d'apporter bien-être à
l'humanité permettre plutôt aider le
monde a toujours été le moteur de cette
réflexion
l'accent a été mis sur ce qui est le
plus important pour la population
mondiale il ne fait aucun doute d'une
chose c'est que c'est un accord qui sert
le monde c'est un accord qui permettra
de soulager les pays pauvres près de la
faillite cela permettra d'aider les
personnes proches de la famille de la
famine cela permettra de stabiliser le
prix et des denrées alimentaires déjà à
des niveaux très élevés à même avant la
guerre et ce qui représente un cauchemar
pour les pays pauvres
l'initiative plus spécifiquement
permettra d'ouvrir
la voie à de grands des
exportations grâce venant de ou grâce à
trois quatre grands ports turcs
le transport les céréales et des
produits alimentaires permettra de
réduire la pression sur les prix est de
réduire également la crise alimentaire
excellences mesdames et messieurs cet
accord n'a pas été facile à obtenir
depuis le début de la guerre j'ai mis en
lumière le fait qu'il n'existe pas de
solution à la crise alimentaire mondiale
sans s'assurer qu'il y ait un accès
complet à aux produits alimentaires
ukrainiens et aux produits alimentaires
et aux engrais russe aujourd'hui nous
avons fait un grand pas en avant pour
atteindre ses objectifs
toutefois le chemin a été long au mois
d'avril
après avoir été reçu par le président
erdogan j'ai rencontré le président
poutine et le président azzedine chih
afin de présenter un plan proposant des
solutions et nous avons travaillé chaque
jour depuis il a fallu énormément
d'efforts et d'engagement des deux côtés
et des semaines de négociations 24 sur
24 l'engagement est aujourd'hui plus
important que jamais cette initiative
doit être totalement mise en oeuvre pour
quoi car le monde a besoin de cet accord
pour lutter contre cette crise
alimentaire mondiale nous comptons sur
le gouvernement de la turquie pour
maintenir son rôle critique à l'avenir
les nations unies seront au présent nous
sommes
nous sommes présents pourra s'assurer
durée de la réussite de ce succès de cet
accord et nous assurerons que les
engagements pris sont respectées je suis
reconnaissant envers les travail des
deux tasses forces des deux groupes de
travail qui ont permis d'avoir une
approche coordonnée martin griffiths le
secrétaire général pour les affaires
humanitaires
et l'organisation internationale des
affaires maritimes se sont concentrés
sur le transport des céréales l'ukraine
par la mer noire
aujourd'hui nous annonçons la création
d'un centre de coordination conjoint
pourra examiner ou pour s'assurer de la
mise en oeuvre de cette forêt là le gros
groupe de travail dirigé par un martin
griffiths a permis d'assurer un accès
sans contrainte des céréales et des
produits alimentaires venant de russie
un accord a pu être trouvé et
j'encourage les différentes parties
prenantes à faire tous les efforts
nécessaires pour as pour respecter leurs
engagements nous devons faire tous les
efforts possibles pour garantir la paix
c'est un accord sans précédent entre
deux partis participant un conflit un
conflit armé qui existe encore
aujourd'hui des gens meurent encore
chaque jour et les combats font rage au
quotidien cette lueur d'espoir sur la
mer noire brice fort aujourd'hui grâce à
l'effort conjoint de nombreuses parties
prenantes en cette période difficile
pour la région et pour le monde que
cette lueur nous guide vers un
allègement des souffrances pour la
population et de une plus grande
stabilité et une plus grande
merci beaucoup monsieur le secrétaire
général
maintenant le président de la république
turque
redjep tayyip erdogan va à prendre la
parole je le prie de bien vouloir
venir au micro
monsieur
chers ministres
chers membres des délégations
je vous salue avec mes sentiments les
plus cordiaux et avec respect
nous sommes à istanbul lieu le lieu de
rencontre des civilisations et des
continents soyez tous les bienvenus en
date du 29 mars
nous avions eu une réunion très
importante suite à celle ci nous sommes
à nouveau ensemble réunis ici
et nous accueillons nous vous
accueillons vous nos chers amis à
l'occasion d'une journée historique à
nouveau istanbul j'en suis
particulièrement ravi
cette crise globale alimentaire
tracassé demande depuis très longtemps
et je nous vivons la fierté de pouvoir
avoir contribué à résoudre cette
situation
de jusqu'à l'afrique au moyen orient
dans le monde entier des milliards
d'êtres humains pouvaient être confronté
à une grave crise alimentaire et tous
ensemble nous allons pouvoir et apporter
une réponse en matière de produits
alimentaires il est évidemment un
impératif de pouvoir assurer la sécurité
alimentaire dans le temps dans le monde
entier il vient en plus la crise due au
réchauffement
climatique qui va probablement avoir une
influence sur la montée des prix de
cette façon nous pourrons également y
contribuer et réduire ses prix là cette
inflation sur les denrées alimentaires
nous pourrons y contribuer grâce à
l'accord qui signe aujourd'hui
évidemment nous ne sommes pas parvenus à
cet accord du jour au lendemain
nous
des entretiens intense avec les
responsables des nations unies notamment
avec nos homologues russes et ukrainiens
également nous étions en permanence en
contact avec eux et les chacun de ces
deux pays avaient des inquiétudes
avaient des attentes nous avons eu un
processus de consultation très intenses
pour parvenir à résoudre des points de
blocage mais ministre en charge des
affaires étrangères et de la défense et
on compte contribuer grandement le
secrétaire général des nations unies et
son équipe y ont également contribué
sera une importance pour arriver à un
accord
en conséquence de tout cela
messieurs poutine et zidane ce qui ont
contribué également l'arrêt à la
signature de cet accord je tenais avait
remercié tout particulièrement grâce au
trafic maritime qui pourra commencer
dans les jours à venir sur la mer noire
il y aura une nouvelle voie qui
permettra au monde de respirer grâce à
ce trafic qui va voir le jour en mer
noire c'est navires pourront circuler en
toute sécurité et un accord a été
compliquée elle a été conclu sur toutes
les parties de ceux de ce transport le
contrôle sera effectué à istanbul grâce
à un centre commun de coordination dont
le centre sera istanbul
le plan devra évidemment être appliquée
avec célérité
de ce point de vue la communauté
internationale devrait également y
contribuer joué un rôle éminent chers
amis il il ya environ quatre mois de
cela nous étions à nouveau à istanbul et
soon aux hospices il ya eu des
entretiens qui ont eu lieu entre la
russie et l'ukraine et nous avions des
espoirs pour que la guerre puisse cesser
incessamment sous peu malheureusement
les évolutions qui ont suivi après cette
réunion dédiée à quatre mois ont
envenimé deux clubs le conflit depuis le
début et nous avons toujours dit qu'il
n'y aurait aucun vainqueur à ce conflit
que tout pas simplement les parties
engagées le monde entier allait perdre
de cette guerre environ depuis cinq mois
ce conflit continue sans arrêt sans
discontinuer et malheureusement des
effets globaux nous avons montré que
nous avions raison de prédire des effets
négatifs de ces 2,7 caire tant que les
armes tonnent ne se feront pas ne se
dément pas évidemment les pertes
humaines augmenteront également cette
guerre ne concerne pas simplement les
parties engagées ne concerne pas
simplement les pays engagés cette guerre
a une influence négative sur le monde
entier sur les populations du monde
entier mais ce n'est pas inscrit dans le
destin nous pouvons empêcher que cela
continue cette guerre entraîne des
victimes humaines des victimes dit de
santé nous voulons que cette guerre
puisse prendre fin le plus rapidement
possible il n'y aura aucun perdant si
nous arrivons à une paix juste
aujourd'hui avec la russie avec
l'ukraine nous avons engagé une étude un
pas important et je pense que cela sera
peut-être du moins gens et l'espoir que
cela pourra ouvrir d'avoir à un nouvel
avenir les évolutions sur le terrain peu
importe dans quel sens elle continue la
guerre quoi qu'il en soit devra se
terminer à la table des négociations
cette ambiance pacifique
que nous avons créé aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'elle pourra servir à
d'autres pas qui seront faits en faveur
de la paix c'est la responsabilité que
nous avons c'est la responsable des
lieux nous avons qui découle de notre
conception de la civilisation
tout d'abord nous continuerons jusqu'à
ce que la paix règne dans cette région
nous ferons tous en tant que pays voisin
a assuré cela je souhaite que dieu nous
aide en ce sens et en terminant mes
propos a obtenu dans mes propos je vous
remercie tous réellement tous pour tous
les efforts que vous avez consentis de
fer est d'accord qui va être signé
aujourd'hui sera porteur de très bonnes
choses pour toute la région pour nos
peuples pour tous les peuples et je
remercie tous ceux en mon nom je
remercie en mon nom et au nom de ma
nation tous ceux qui ont contribué à la
réalisation de cet accord une fois de
plus je vous salue tous avec respect
nous remercions de notre président de la
république pour les propos qu'il vient
de tenir
monsieur le président de la république
monsieur le secrétaire général
la république turque la fédération de
russie la république d'ukraine yens vont
signer sous l'égide des nations unies
le document dont il est question
aujourd'hui
la ministère de la défense de la
république turque et le ministère de la
défense de la fédération de russie vont
signer un accord afin d'assurer le
transport sécurisé des denrées
alimentaires décès réel à partir des
ports d'ukraine c'est le prémice la
défense turque hulusi à qu'argent et au
nom de la fédération de russie le
ministre de la défense sergueï choïgou
qui vont venir
et au nom de la délation unies le
secrétaire général
antonio guterres est ce qu'ils vont
procéder à la signature de cet accord
plus
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc pour cet accord qui a été
signé par les trois parties oui mais
voilà les faits le
ministère des infrastructures d'ukraine
sous l'égide des nations unies vont
signer un accord en rapport avec le
transport sécurisé des denrées
alimentaires des céréales à partir des
ports d'ukraine au nom de la république
de turquie russia car le ministre de la
défense au nom de l'ukraine oleksandr
aubrac off et au nom des nations unies
le secrétaire général antonio guterres s
et donc bruno on va expliquer en train
de se passer russes et ukrainiens ne
s'assoit pas à la même table pour signer
oui donc c'est une cérémonie d'accord un
peu particulière de signature d'accords
un peu particulière puisque les deux
pays effectivement sont en guerre dont
il ya deux accords miroir si vous voulez
qu'ils ont été signés l'un par les
russes l'autre par les ukrainiens à
chaque fois avec les turcs et avec le
secrétaire général des nations unies
mais effectivement envoyé à l'image le
secrétaire général de l'onu le président
turc et à chaque fois le ministre turc
est le représentant russe puis le
représentant ukrainien il n'est pas
question que les deux soient à la même
table c'est effectivement la signature
d'un accord dans un contexte de conflit
donc les deux pays ne veulent pas se
trouver à la même table au même moment
et on va rappeler ce que prévoit cet
accord bruno exactement alors pour faire
simple cet accord il permet de débloquer
les ports d'ukrainiens où sont stockés
25 millions de tonnes de céréales est
donc un environnement sûr pour que les
navires puissent quitter ses ports et
être conduit alors d'abord dans les eaux
territoriales ukrainienne par des
navires ukrainien et ensuite après
vérifications peuvent se rendre dans les
les détroits turcs et donc ensuite au
delà de ces détroit évidemment se rendre
dans les différentes destinations au
proche orient en afrique du nord et
parfois dans le reste du monde pour donc
délivrer ces millions de tonnes
qu'attendent un peu désespérément
effectivement des millions de personnes
il ya un point crucial on va terminer là
dessus bruno ce centre de coordination
conjoint qui sera donc à istanbul oui la
la la la turquie qui renforce un son
rôle de médiateur et on a vu on pourra
peut-être le développer que le président
r douanes compte bien profiter de ces
accords pour relancer aussi son rôle de
médiateur plus globalement sur le
conflit lui-même mais le centre de
contrôle conjoint effectivement sera
établir il se remet au cirque là les
parties russe et ukrainienne vont
contrôler que tout se passe bien à bord
qu'il n'ya pas d'armes ça c'est
l'inquiétude des russes qu'il n'ya pas
d'armes vu que pour en faveur de
l'ukraine qui se trouveraient à bord des
navires quand il retourne
am envers l'ukraine voilà il y aura ce
cette tour de contrôle si vous voulez
conjointement qui permettra en principe
aux deux parties d'être relativement
sereine vis-à-vis de l'exportation de 6
millions de tonnes de céréales
ukrainiennes et russes aussi voilà donc
pour cette cérémonie de signature de cet
accord très attendue par le monde depuis
et des mois vous l'avez vécu en direct
sur france 24